our hearts are really heavy tonight here
at Fox and of course the sad news
Charles Krauthammer beloved columnist
father husband of course contributor to
Fox News pilot surprise winner political
commentator died today at age 68 his
death was a shock but of course was not
unexpected he told us two weeks ago that
he had terminal cancer and not too long
to live but Charles became an almost
kind of larger-than-life figure during
his decade here at Fox News he was one
of the most respected political analysts
in Washington I think in the United
States no doubt about it and a beloved
presence in the news room here and
Charles was seldom at a loss for words
but he often put others in that position
as I know personally but it was his
humor I think that a lot of us as we
smile tonight remembering him are
thinking about tonight all kinds of
folks for the last year you know in the
end Hillary's not gonna run and I'd said
a hundred percent she's running unless
she's struck by lightning there was no
lightning that I could see I think there
are some people who don't you know who
get in and they're not gonna get out
unless they're beaten speaking as a
amateur psychiatrist so what if you look
like a Lucky Luciano and that's Trump
for me I'm gonna take that okay
Mars Polar Lander says what's what's the
difference between a Democrat and a
socialist a Democrat is a socialist with
a filter are we gonna fight like they
did I said here a week ago that it will
snow in hell before the Obama DOJ goes
after Hillary I'm willing to entertain a
belief in climate change that part
what's bringing our distinguished panel
of Charles colleagues to discuss its
remarkable life and career and on the
phone with us is Fox News chief
political anchor and special report
anchor Bret Baier here in the studio of
course Fox News senior political analyst
Brit Hume associate editor and columnist
at RealClearPolitics
AV Stoddard and Fox News contributor
Charlie heard opinion editor and
columnist for The Washington Times all
of you a sad night but boy do we we have
so many all of us have so many memories
of Charles before we go to the panel
here Brett you sat in this seat so many
nights of course as did Brit Hume with
Charles to your right and it was always
a rollicking ride in commercial breaks
where all the fun usually happens and in
the online special show where Charles
was even funnier than he was on the
panel some reflections tonight yeah you
know it's a bittersweet moment because I
like looking back at those moments and
the fun and the humor I just talked to
Daniel who was at his dad's side along
with Robin his wife and they've been
heartened by some of these memories and
some of the stories and looking at their
dad in his prime Charles could lighten
up a room he could crack a joke
he was my first baseman there on the
panel for almost ten years and before
that alongside Brit Hume and he could
cut through the noise of the day and
then
guess up in the commercial breaks like
nobody else good so he just had a gift
his writing was unlike I don't think
you're gonna see another columnist that
had his penetrating than a wisdom and
thoughts and we're going to try to use
that as we go on because these comments
is on every issue on the day and we'll
bring him into the conversation as we go
forward
Brett him you know we've known this was
coming for some weeks now barely lessens
the sadness of this moment but this that
what that means is that Charles had a
chance in the last few weeks of his life
to hear how we all felt about him the
kind of tribute just heard from Brad but
some of the rest of has been saying all
day it wasn't just that he was so
brilliant although he certainly was he
was also very so very kind and funny and
we loved him all of us around here loved
those of us who might be considered big
shots loved him everybody else loved him
as well so I hope he knew that I suspect
he did and I'm glad for that tonight and
the from everyone from the makeup artist
the guys behind the camera who do such
great work and women behind the behind
the scenes and everyone knew him he
didn't want he didn't want to be treated
differently though than anyone else
people you pointed that out you talk
about the breaks when I was back in the
days when I was doing a special report
and Charles was on
he would come in early because of the
wheelchair because it took a little
longer to get him in position so he
didn't come in with the other panelists
he came in earlier which meant that
there were two commercial breaks between
the time he arrived and the time the
rest of the panel came in that I got to
spend with Charles and and every now and
then he would say a kind word to me
about my work and I always felt like you
know the earth and everything that was
in it had just been conferred upon me
when I got a compliment from Charles
good how much how much I respect him and
we all did and how much I loved him a B
there was a moment on The Daily Show
that I had not seen until just before
this show tonight I'd like your reaction
and your thoughts let's watch 30 years
do you ever look back on some of these
writings and think what was I thinking
it's worse than that
right when the worst part of writing the
book was going all the way back and
reading the million words I've written I
couldn't believe I'd written summer
nights so there's been so much what's
the growth process been like the growth
process yes well I was once a liberal so
the early writings showed hope and then
came change you sat next to him on so
many so many evenings yes brilliant well
I wrote about him last week and I said
that they only debate that I ever won in
nine years was on the supercommittee
which was the debt cutting committee
which fell flat on his face but he wrote
with with great hope about how it might
all work out and it was really gonna be
a great opportunity and when I busted
him about it when it all folded he said
well that was one of the times where I
just once wasn't cynical enough and that
was really the only he was never wrong
if his if his prediction didn't come
true usually cuz he hadn't been cynical
enough but for someone who was so
cynical
he was also always full of hope and joy
and he really delighted in the little
things and and that was an incredible
combination so stoic so strong because
this is because of his battle and what
he had just her mount in the wake of it
but then just someone who really
delighted in just the the warmth and
exchange with people he loved people and
we had we had a night right here at this
table I'll never forget it was early on
when I didn't know him well and I was
seated in between them and Steve and
Brett I think we're making some college
over drinking jokes or something and out
of nowhere Gerald said that commercial
always stayed with me Shafer it's the
only beer to have when you're having
more than one and then he paused
perfectly time more than one would and
then of course it was right back to the
panel and we were back on camera I was
practically under this table with his
comedic timing was unbelievable but also
sometimes he just had the delight of a
small kid it was really something to
behold and it a psychiatry
Harvard Medical School Pulitzer Prize
more Awards than we can we can list here
but Charles went when he wrote about a
political movement or event he wrote
about it in a way that I don't know you
could cut he cut through where so many
others were mired in minutiae on
President Reagan I love this part of
course this is after Reagan's death he
wrote optimism is the perfect way to
trivialize everything that Reagan was or
did optimism every other person on the
number-6 bus is an optimist
what distinguish Reagan was that was
what he did and said Reagan was
optimistic about America amid the
cynicism and general retreat of the
post-vietnam era because he believed
unfashionably that America was both
great and good and I loved because it
was like Reagan so he's like an old
uncle he's OE break-ins are so
optimistic but it was optimistic about
the goodness of America that that and I
love the fact that he pointed that out
cuz he always was cutting against the
conventional wisdom and that of course
in and of itself is the ultimate
optimistic view of of America of course
I've had the pleasure of knowing Charles
far less than anybody sitting at this
table but I remember being a little boy
a younger boy growing up in a small town
and we got the Washington Post and I
remember my father would rip out the his
columns and send them to me and give
them to me and and that had a profound
impact on my interest in newspapers and
obviously politics he was obviously
brilliant funny all these things but the
title of his book things that matter I
think was the most perfect title of a
book for him because what he did better
than anything else was to cut through
all the noise and put everything into
perspective
with that way with the things that were
important and the things like he said
the things that mattered think about
that Laura that book was a collection
collection spatially don't sell like
hotcakes for years and I think people
are still buying it I've got a copy of
it I was on the train yesterday come
back from New York and I saw there's a
guy sitting there you know
one of the tables reading that book also
I do want to mention Brett's special
which we referred to throughout the
night but people have to take that hour
and sit down it is absolutely
breathtaking yeah well tomorrow night 9
p.m. on Fox News and so many I mean I
can't wait to watch it I've heard I've
seen bits and pieces but I haven't
watched the whole thing
Bret the night after night after night
election night's primary night's look a
crown hammer at it you know was was
tough on the Trump campaign but also
very fair after Trump you know he and I
got into some legendary battles on the
panel in the in the run-up to the
election with George will his the best
friend and and it was a spirited debate
was always so much fun though he was
such a great sparring partner on the
issue of rising populism versus the old
Bush globalism interventionism he loved
the philosophical back-and-forth that I
think makes special report such an
important show to have featured him and
I know Brit Hume was the first one to
really put you put him on this show that
show first and that that made the
difference on that panel he really I
mean I know you've missed him since
we've all missed him here at Fox yeah he
really was a powerhouse and he loves
getting into the politics he loved
engaging with you and Tucker and and
others on on you know the issues of the
day politically wise political wise I
did that candidate casino where I tried
to get panelist to put chips at bets on
potential candidates and we had 17 at
the beginning of this process
Republicans and so he did not put any
money on Trump and eventually he was
grudgingly putting five and 10 and he
would always put five five chip on wine
women and song and he he just had a
great time with it he was somebody who I
think touch people in a way that even if
you didn't agree with him you kind of
nodded your head and said all right I
get that
Brett Trump for you I mean we think of
what's happening to the big immigration
debate this
parading the families and I just want to
know what to Krauthammer would be saying
me too okay what would he say what would
he say about the Nazi concentration camp
what is this about Charles he was
greatly offended by Trump Trump was
absolutely not yeah he would once he
thought as just George will Trump is a
horrible vulgarity I mean that he did
believe that right not well red etc and
mendacious and all the rest of no love
lost exactly but once Trump was
nominated and in particular after he
became president I think Charles like
some of the rest of us was deeply
offended by the coverage of him and he
was very fair to Trump during the course
of his presidency as for as long as you
know Charles was able to able to
witnesses which was you know the
excessive a year before we before we
lost him to this terrible illness he had
a column in 2011 a B it was called alone
in the universe it's one of those
columns you see the titles I got to read
it so I went back and read it today this
is at the end we was talking about how
many galaxies constellations life on
other planets and so forth and he said
sit at the end we grow justly weary of
our politics but we must remember this
politics in all its grubby grasping
corrupt contemptible manifestations is
sovereign in human affairs everything
ultimately rests upon it fairly or not
politics is the driver of history no I
think I debate him on that because I
don't know Paulo I don't know if
politics is that important in most
people's lives but it was important to
him and he thought the debates that we
were having and of course that was 2011
that was during the Obama administration
all the big you know the questions about
how we handle terror and and and other
countries foreign affairs were very
important but he he always had a very
interesting kind of clinical take
psychiatrists take on the afterlife
whether there was an afterlife and I
just wonder like I just want to have a
conversation about their like when I
read this way I'm like this is why I
love being on the Krauthammer I know we
all do but that's what that's what we're
so wonderful about his columns as they
would go off on all these other huge
tracks being a perspective was so broad
but the thing about how much he loved
politics and believed it was an
important the debate and the discourse
was so important
even though it's eroded and degraded so
rapidly he he really believed that
everyone should be persuadable at least
around the edges and he was he didn't
like people who weren't willing to just
be persuaded a bit here and there and so
he would tried to bring that to his
argument and and most of the time it
works on people they would say even if I
didn't agree at the end I really saw how
well he made the point and so he engaged
them and and that was an art of
persuasion in itself Charlie you've
written a lot of columns in your in your
day and coverage on being a columnist he
wrote longevity for a columnist is a
simple proposition once you start you
don't stop you do it until you die or
can no longer put a sentence together
it's always been my intention to die at
my desk although my most cherished
ambition is to outlive the estate tax
well he almost did we've doubled the
estate you know exemption so he's he did
pretty well on that but again humor in
the in the face of difficulty and I
don't know that was that wasn't just
another you're close but III think you
would he would agree with you in in
terms of politics is not what everything
is about
he is right politics is about power it's
about who should govern and in that
respect it is the most important thing
because it's kind of how we determine
what what rights we have but at the end
of the day he wanted he wanted to go to
a baseball game he would have loved to
have been at the Nets game tonight he
would have been maybe it to him tonight
and he would have been embarrassed by
that but but he would have loved to have
been there and I don't know anybody I
don't know anybody who squeezed more out
of life than dr. grandma guys thank you
so much tonight
brett-brett Abie and Charles of course
thank you all so much
We will miss you Charles greatly